hey there and welcome to this second
lesson on the basics of lights and
shadows in after effects and how to give
depth
to
your motion design so
for this example i want to create
i want to fly down a tunnel and we've
all seen tunnel fly throughs but i'm
just going to show you how much more
interesting it can be by adding a light
so it's a pretty basic example here okay
so
um i don't want the fill
some turn off fill here
and i do want a stroke
i want my rectangle to be a square so
let's do
maybe 500 by 500.
let's see what that does and then let's
crank the stroke way up to make maybe
250.
yeah let's try 250.
and let's make it a really bright
pink will work just fine
and next i'm going to make it a 3d layer
and we'll call it
rectangle
i'm going to duplicate it
bring this one underneath actually we'll
just leave it in front here
position and we're going to make the
position we're gonna make them 500
pixels
uh we'll do negative
500 pixels so each one of these is in
front of the the last and we'll just
make this one
[Music]
blue
and we'll duplicate it again
and we'll make it
negative 1000
and this one will be
maybe in this kind of cyan
duplicate again
position we'll do negative
1500 and this one will be
maybe this bright green and we'll
duplicate it one more time
and we'll do
negative 2 000
and we'll make this one
maybe this orange
so the next thing we'll do is we're
going to add a new camera
and we'll make it
50. like that
hit p for position set a keyframe
and i'm just going to get the beginning
of my timeline here and i'm going to hit
c
three times to do my zoom tool i'm just
going to push in
so maybe we just start on black like
that
and then we end
maybe we just end
i don't know something like this
yeah and if we fly through it
you can see what's going on here i
actually need to change again i'm on
cinema 4d
so i want to change it to classic 3d
okay
you can see how much quicker it moves
now
so i'm flying through here so you know
it's an interesting tunnel we're just
kind of flying through it uh
you can kind of tell it's
3d but to make it even more dimensional
we're going to add a light
clear new light and we're going to add
let's do a point light
as i mentioned that's my favorite type
of light to add
and if i go to two views here
you can see here's where my light is
and
[Music]
there are several layers past this light
like here's
rectangle three but because it's in
front of that light it's not being lit
right so if i just pull this light back
you can see what happens here
is it's lighting these other layers up
and i think the orange layer was was the
um
furthest forward layer
so i think we're good there
go back to one view
and a little bit more depth but i still
want some shadows to be projected and
they're not and if i open up my point
light here i can hit a a to open it up i
can see here it is casting shadows it's
turned on
it could be turned off but i haven't
turned on
but these layers are not projecting any
shadows so we need to
select all of these layers and we're
going to hit aa again and anytime you
hit up hit aaa it opens up
material options for a 3d layer it opens
up light options for a light
camera options for a camera aaa really
quickly on your keyboard so we can see
here that
rectangle says cast shadows off it
accepts lights yes that's on cache
shutters is off so if we hit
click that to on it's going to turn all
of them on because we have all of these
layers selected so now all of a sudden
we can see some shadows in there right
so if we preview this
um remember we are at half red so we can
see some some shadows going on here i
don't love these shadows
um they're really
you know pretty trippy looking actually
there's some artifacting going on like i
see especially right in here
and i'm wondering if that is because i'm
half resolution if i go full res boom
there we go
there it looks much nicer
i will tell you a trick here a pro tip
if you do have very large layers
and you're projecting very large shadows
from those layers sometimes you're going
to need to go in your composition
settings
and you're going to need to go into
advanced
actually it's 3d render
and because we're
classic 3d
we're going to click options
and shadow map resolution defaults to
comp size sometimes you have to bump
that up to a much higher number like
this now this will increase your render
times your preview times so if you can
you want to get away with comp size but
sometimes you can't so you can get to
that through composition settings
3d renderer here classic 3d or you can
click up here under render classic 3d as
well
and go into options here
so there we are
i'm going to hit a aa on my keyboard and
i'm going to turn the shadow diffusion
up
maybe like 100 pixels
something like that
that looks a little bit nicer it's also
very dark my shadow darkness is 151
percent
so let's just do
i don't know 80
see what that looks like that's much
nicer
something else i think could use a
little bit of help here is
maybe the position of the light so if i
select the light here
and just kind of move around you can see
how the shadows move
you know based on the position that
light
i do like it a little bit high up like
that so let's preview this and see how
it looks
okay so there it goes and it looks
pretty dope it's my favorite word of the
2020 dope
um
i like it so you can see here that the
light and shadows add a lot of depth to
this very simple setup
and this is a very simple you know
example of what you can do with lights
and shadows we'll move into some more
complicated ones here in just a moment
but yeah it looks really nice so
um with lights and shadows
and
without
lights and shadows and of course for
some reason my computer is just
dogging it
today
um but before i stop this video i do
want to show you let's just take a look
really quickly
at the difference between so we are
using a point light which i said is one
of my favorite types of lights to use
and we'll change this here in just a
second to a spotlight
and then to a
ambient light and a parallel light so
you can get an idea but again here we
are back at
no point light
no any type of light very flat
and there we go again with the
very basic point light setup one light
you could add multiple point lights to
this make it more interesting
but let's just go right here
let me save this puppy and let's just uh
change this from layer oh actually here
before we did so you can see now all of
a sudden we have point light options
here i just mentioned in video one
sometimes you see this sometimes you
don't
uh which is nice it's it's here so we
can change it to spotlight
and let's see what happens here
finally not much of a change here and i
think that's because the light is fully
encompassed you can see here the cone is
way outside of our box so if i was to
bring in
this cone obviously this is going to
make it look you know much different a
lot more vignetting on the sides uh
we'll go back to a parallel let's see
what the parallel looks like
very
harsh
shadows so for this parallel light i'm
actually going to open up the transform
properties and drop the position and you
can see here you can't rotate a parallel
light
uh nothing it's just point of interest
in position so we'll just move the
position down
maybe something like that and
yeah
i don't love that
um and then you know maybe bring the uh
intensity up on it
yeah just
not one of my favorite types of lights
so let's actually undo all this
and let's bring it
back
to a point and then we'll do one more
which is ambient
and ambient it's not going to create any
shadow
it's just flat just like that so i'll
undo that and let's just say for some
reason we wanted to give it just a
little bit more light in there that's
when i would create a second light this
would be my
ambient light
change it from type to ambient and we'll
bring down the intensity
and just fill in some of these spots
so you can see now everything's a little
bit uh brighter a little bit more light
going on but there are still some nice
shadows in there so i'd hit aa on my
keyboard
maybe take this down even more you know
i tend to like things a little darker
in my own personal style
so for me
bringing an ambient light i bring it way
down
if you have a brighter style you'd want
more ambient light so without
width
maybe i bring that up just a hair so
there you go that is how to that's a
simple way to use lights
on a tunnel to give more depth let's
move on to
another lesson
[Music]
you